so Stephen if someone were to ask you
hey what is this book about what would
you say I would say it's sort of the
most accurate depiction possible on the
inside of a campaign during the last
American election where where American
democracy actually collapses
um under the weight of distrust and
under the weight of you know a
collapsing electoral system and so it's
a you know a paranoid political thriller
that's accurate have you got any
feedback uh as yet well I got I mean the
people who read it really liked it I
mean the Publisher's weekly like I've
I've never actually had a start review
I've never had a pre-review for a book
go as well as like be as nice as that
one where it's like this is a really
great working thriller so I was I was
pretty stoked by that and yeah the
response I've had has been great how
about you you know what's funny I don't
know if this is an insult to my previous
books but they were like I'm shocked at
how much I like this
race well I mean it makes sense because
it's like it's you know it's a it's a
thriller like it's a straight Thriller
and but it also contains sort of more
you know intimate information about
political life and I think I think those
two in combination are pretty
interesting to read right like I think
those are I think those are those are
sort of more fun things to read than
than just like uh you know politics
right like and it's sort of it's sort of
a different take on it I think and
um it's a very unusual book like I
looked at it again last night and I was
like we have actually written something
that's pretty particular like I don't
think there's another example of a book
really like this one
um but you know I mean I think that
that's exciting too right like that's
that it's it's strange yeah what
multiple people have said to me is they
felt like they learned something uh and
they were entertained which I feel like
is mission accomplished for us exactly
yeah you know our goal is to entertain
yes but it was also to convey various
messages uh so let's talk about who the
heck you are how you came to this topic
how we ended up writing this book
together so you wrote a book the next
civil war that came out gosh now about
two years ago and it was provocatively
meant to say look uh the United States
has very very clear
signs of disintegration that other
societies have gone through and it's not
exceptional in this regard uh what was
the process like researching that book
uh and then putting it down this would
work a non-fiction yeah and then the
response thereafter
well in in some ways it was similar to
our project because it was like there
were imagined scenarios of what an
American breakdown would look like and
then it was deeply researched right so I
mean what it did was it like the
research was like a lot of phone calls
with experts and also you know we live
in an age of sort of unbelievable
modeling uh from from a lot of different
viewpoints agricultural uh environmental
political uh economic you know like
there just are these really really
functional models and I wanted to sort
of basically take those models and then
put flesh on the bones right like make
it make people understand what you know
what it means if a hurricane hits New
York which all the models say that it
will right and uh you know so that was
kind of the process there then there was
of course the journalistic process of
like going out and talking to members of
the extreme rights which was you know
because I looked like one of them it was
very easy for me to you know get access
to them them and they were all very
polite and nice to talk to with me and
so it was talking to them going doing
things like going to gun shows in
Oklahoma a prepper conventions in Ohio
talking to people of that nature so it
was It was kind of an all it was like an
all methods that I could think of to do
and it really you know what was so
interesting to me about our project is
that in that book I didn't really talk
about electoral politics right like I
didn't really because like I felt like
the models that I wanted to bring in the
next civil war were ones that I felt I
could Define like some are stronger than
others but I could I could inform the
reader of the strength of them right so
it's like the environmental models are
incredibly strong they just are
incredibly predictably strong the
economic models are incredibly weak I'll
give you the best ones I'll show you how
they work but like they're not they're
not effective but with electoral
politics I really couldn't get
reliable information like everyone has
an agenda everyone is hiding something
and that's when that's why when you came
along with this idea I really felt like
this is a unique opportunity right like
this is this is a unique chance to
actually get a reliable point of view on
the state of American of electoral
politics in the United States and you
know you to your credit you absolutely
gave that to me and it's in the book
yeah yeah so we were both tracking down
some version of the truth and some
version of the not so distant future
yeah and and that's what excited me is
that there was a sense and I think other
people who read this have also gotten
the senses like like that they they come
back and say you know I find this
eminently plausible
um which is what makes it scary
um but also hopefully valuable
yeah that's the idea that I mean that's
what yeah and entertaining I hope you
know like entertaining but Publishers
Weekly thought it was really
entertaining I mean that was what I I
was I was you know I I assumed we get
the uh the credit from like it being
truth-telling like I I because I we
worked hard with that you know like I
thought we I like I thought we got that
but like the entertaining thing like is
a little trickier and you know and and I
and I think we've got that too which is
which is nice you know which is like a
it's a it's a good bonus yeah it is a
entertaining multiple people have said
to me it reads like a movie or a TV show
and there are folks in Hollywood who are
looking at potentially turning it into
uh movie or TV show so this could be
coming to screens near people hopefully
people will run out and buy the book and
enjoy it and then X months later if it
shows up on your TV screen you can be
like oh and you could be in the know and
say oh that happened but I I will say
I'd be excited about that because the
the story does uh read like a thriller
and that's a credit to you Stephen it is
I mean it's just a straight Thriller
right I mean I I felt like we were I was
really trying to imitate those great
Thrillers of the 60s like you know like
like the uh seven days of May uh
Manchurian Candidate
um those are those are just great great
books you know and like the political
thriller as it's come to is just a
little different than those like they
tend to be a lot longer and a lot more
um you know with a lot more
State stages and also more lengthily
written like the more more voluminously
written but I wanted to be concise you
know also like I I feel like there's a
sense of relentlessness like that's like
part of the times we live in right this
feeling of like this Relentless March of
time like things speeding up rapidly and
you know those old books really had that
way of building that right into the
structure of the story and
um and like that and I I wanted to get
that too because it seems to fit right
if it's the moment if it's the story if
it's you know where we are at
[Music]
guys if you really
really it'll notify you every time we
have a bang-up new guest thank you